[Music]
and then one day I was leaving my
parking lot so on the sidewalk I took
the corner of the building to go home
and there he passed 2 cm from me
so actually I was I had  very
afraid
[Music]
I think that in fact scooters
are dangerous we are constantly
confronted with scooters which
cross the streets and which are
without sound warning so obviously there are
risks for pedestrians
now ban 100% it's
perhaps a little hard to see if it can
be more regulated in terms of already
having a helmet limit the speed
respect the voices the voices the
road voices and not the sidewalks
cross the streets so maybe  put
verbalizations for people who
are a little too crazy we're going to say
on the road
[Music]